on the coronavirus now uh the ons has
just released the
latest data on covered 19 deaths in
england and wales in the week leading up
to january the 15th uh let's bring in
our economics editor
ed conway who's been going through this
ed ed what are we learning from the
office for national statistics
uh well i mean the numbers throughout on
this have been
thoroughly depressing and i'm afraid you
know it's another week of
depressing news in terms of deaths what
the ons does is they look
at the number of deaths across england
and wales they also collate numbers
coming from scotland as well and from
northern ireland and
it is a slightly different measure of
people who have died of covert 19
to the one that we get from the
government on their dashboard each day
but by some people's
yardsticks this is the more
comprehensive measure and according to
this ons
measure we have now surpassed a hundred
thousand deaths in the uk
from covert 19 they say it's up to about
107
000 close to 108 000 as of the 15th
of january and that number expected to
to mount further so
a hundred and seven hundred and eight
thousand uh
deaths from covert 19. it is one of
those moments
you know none of us wanted to report it
is thoroughly
depressing but nonetheless that is what
the figures are suggesting and it's
worth just underlining you know there
are various different ways of measuring
this we will later on
this afternoon get numbers from
department for health and social care
of uh what they see as their death toll
for for cover 19
it is very close to a hundred thousand
uh the ons death toll
is slightly less up to date so it only
goes at the moment up to the 15th of
january
but it is more comprehensive because it
includes some deaths
uh in spring of last year that weren't
necessarily that there was less testing
going on there
and whereas the official numbers from
the government are only based on
when someone has had a positive covert
19 test and then has died
28 days within 28 days of that the ons
numbers
are based on where covid19 is mentioned
on the death certificate and so covered
slightly more of the deaths that we saw
uh in the spring of last year
it is a terrible number it is a kind of
a testament i suppose to the scale uh of
this pandemic
but beneath this figure are many
thousands of families who have suffered
losses
uh across this country and unfortunately
those numbers
are getting worse the one thing i would
just say in in in summation is that at
least
the case numbers are going down so we
may now be at the highest point for
deaths but nonetheless
they are continuing to go up in terms of
new deaths we're getting every day